and action
yummy Sly enjoys putting me through
punishment he really does he's so
mischievous but um you know in the Rocky
the rocky films it's like it's like a
badge of honor to take a real punch and
when you do slow-mo shots you can't fake
it you know because if you you know if
you did a slow-mo shot and it was a miss
you would see the space and it just
wouldn't It wouldn't connect so you have
to take a real punch and Sly was like
you know he was sitting in the corner he
was pacing he was kind of looking like
nah it's not going to work it's not
going to work and he finally gets up and
says mike listen you got to take a real
punch and I'm like oh okay did you do it
he said yeah I did I did it a bunch of
times okay if you did it I'll do it and
and we ended up setting up the the
cameras and we uh I took her okay so
this so this is this is Michael B Jordan
uh taking a real Punch Yeah background
watching and action
oh my God